this video is sponsored by nordvpn
i need this today health and fitness so
if building stronger and more mobile
ankles is not currently a priority of
yours then it probably should be your
ankles are essentially the bridge
between your feet the ground and your
upper body they provide all the
information you need to balance to
produce force to move quickly and
powerfully and at the same time they're
responsible for a whole lot of falls and
accidents when they get too weak and
they can greatly limit your range of
motion if you want to improve your squat
if you want to jump higher run faster if
you want to balance better if you want
to lunge deeper if you want to cut and
be better at sports then training your
ankles specifically is a fantastic use
of your time i'm going to show you how
to do that now and as someone who
actually broke their ankle when i was a
young teenager by getting it stuck in a
rabbit hole true story i'm someone who
knows the importance of training strong
and mobile ankles and in fact some of
the tips i'm going to share with you
here have helped me to reduce issues
with my mobility and with pain that
bugged me for decades so hopefully it
can do the same for you so the ankle
joint or the talo cruel joint is a hinge
synovial joint this means it bends like
this up and down no directions and it's
responsible for plantar flexion and
dorsiflexion raising your foot upwards
and pushing it back downwards most
people don't realize that other
movements of the foot such as inversion
and
are actually handled by other joints
that are located very near to the talo
cruel joint but they all work in tandem
where we can collectively call them the
ankles in this case the sub-tail our
joint is responsible for that inversion
and e-version tilting the foot these
ways and we also have lots of joints
actually within the foot that work in
tandem with the ankle to bend and flex
the ankle especially when we land in
rabbit holes the job of all these joints
is to provide mobility and stability at
the same time we want that mobility so
that we can get down to a deep squat so
we can lunge forwards lean over our feet
and so our feet can move around with the
ground underneath without necessarily
bringing our body with them at the same
time we also want to be able to
stabilize this joint in order to drive
power strongly off of the ground if it
was wobbling around all over the place
we wouldn't be able to do that we'd be
at risk of twisting our ankle or
injuring ourselves otherwise as with
many of the other joints that we've
looked at in this series the ankle
joints are controlled by muscles that
aren't actually located in the ankle
rather they're located in the calf and
in the shin
and even inside the foot in particular
the muscles responsible for inversion
and e version of the foot of the
tibialis anterior and the calves and as
you can imagine these are perfectly
strong enough to prevent you from
tipping over by tilting your ankle you
have more than enough strength to do
that so we're looking at building up the
sensitivity in the area that means
listening to the muscle spindles the
proprioceptors in the muscles that tell
us about how long the muscle is and
whether or not it needs to contract
again
one way we can go about training this is
with something that's very popular right
now on instagram and social media that's
ust or unstable surface training
essentially training on a balance board
like this one
however while this can in theory improve
the sensitivity in these muscles and
help you to balance better it's actually
also a very controversial subject and
the reason for this is that studies
don't actually support it as being
effective for the general public the
reason for this being that you already
have enough strength and enough
sensitivity in those muscle spindles
and this isn't going to do that much to
change it or at least in theory
the problem is a lot of those studies
look at wobble boards these kind of blue
wobble boards that don't provide all
that much stimulation and if we replace
one of these
for a slack line
the research on slack lining shows the
exact opposite this can absolutely
improve your running speed your jumping
height and greatly reduce your chances
of injury this of course is because
slacklining is so much more difficult it
provides so much more of a stimulus for
encouraging change and growth for the
ankles and for the proprioceptors
the issue might not be with unstable
surface training in general but with the
difficulty level of what we're used to
using
and this type of training has a ton of
other benefits too from training your
core to improving your body awareness
it's been shown to improve brain
plasticity so it's a fantastic tool in
general
this is my first time ever trying slack
lining and it's pretty difficult as you
can tell i would recommend getting a
spotter if you're trying this for the
first time don't be a fool like me
pretty sure i set mine up wrong i think
i had too much slack in it for sure
maybe it was too close to the ground i
don't know so apologies to the
slacklining community please don't be
too mad at me but it is a ton of fun you
can really feel it in your core and it
really ties back to what i was talking
about in my black widow training video
have to really relax the body you can't
tense up if you want to be successful so
definitely something i'm going to be
exploring more in future i might do a
whole video on balanced training in
general let me know in the comments if
that's something you'd like to see
also guys
nordvpn right
so nordvpn is a virtual private network
that provides users with a safer way to
surf the internet essentially a vpn
works by acting as a middleman between
your data and the sites that you surf so
this means those sites never actually
get to see your personal information
that in turn makes surfing the web that
much safer bruce wayne wouldn't browse
the web without adequate protection in
place so neither should you but that's
not all that nordvpn can do for you
because you can root your traffic via
any of nordvpn's servers located all
around the world you can also view
content that's normally restricted to
those regions so if there's a show you
want to stream that isn't normally
available in your country but no problem
nordvpn works on tons of devices and is
really easy to use pioneer viewers can
get access to an exclusive deal by going
to nordvpn.com forward slash the bioneer
there's a 30-day money-back guarantee as
well so it's completely risk-free
a huge thank you to nordvpn once again
for sponsoring this video and helping me
make more of the content that i love and
the other way you do this which any long
time viewers are already gonna know what
i'm gonna say is by using barefoot shoes
and my sock is cold and wet basically
barefoot shoes allow your foot to move
the way it's supposed to when it hits
the ground so that it can actually flex
and bend with the contours of the floor
at the same time that provides you with
all that extra proprioception which lets
your ankle adjust and your legs adjust
to prevent yourself from falling over
and injuring yourself your foot actually
has all these reflexes built into it
like the plantar reflex when you
stimulate the sole of the foot this
should cause flexion in the big toe
things like this allow your foot to
naturally get into the strongest
position around the ground so that you
can push off of it and this helps the
ankle immensely if you're wearing big
thick soles on your shoes this deadens
all of that input and
completely renders those joints and
muscles useless thereby massively
increasing your chances of injury and
this has practical benefits studies show
that habitual barefoot running can
actually improve your sprint times when
under normal circumstances it's now due
stability of the ankle how do we make
the ankle stronger so that we can push
off a bit more powerfully jump higher
and run faster even more so well
something we want to look at here is
actually called ankle stiffness this is
tendon hysteresis you want to look at
how much energy we can transfer through
the achilles tendon without letting our
foot bend when you think about a
sprinter they're essentially keeping
their foot essentially moving in a very
narrow range of motion this is almost a
static contraction in the calf and this
is what's going to allow you to transfer
energy to the ground
and a great way you can do this
is with skipping
better yet
single leg skipping
here i'm returning the energy to the
ground
using my ankle
another way to strengthen that tendon
is with a deep deficit curve phrase by
getting that stretch on the tendon going
through the full range of motion
as for strengthening the tibialis
anterior you've got the knees over toes
guys tibialis raises which i've talked
about in the past so i won't go into in
great detail here you're gonna just walk
around on your heels with your toes
lifted up in dorsiflexion this is a
great way to train incidentally and heal
sprints are fantastic because you need
to pull the foot up further because
you're running up an incline and this
can also reduce the amount of impact
also involved in moving the ankle
powerfully are the muscles that control
the toes for example you have the flexor
digitorum longus which connects the four
smaller toes to the tibialis posterior
this is also actually responsible for
rotating the foot outwards and you have
the flexor hellucious longus which
connects the big toe to the gastromanous
and this of course helps you to push off
the ground as well the flexor digitorum
along us is actually also responsible
for maintaining the arch of the foot
which is very important for getting that
tripod foot doing a correct squatting
movement so these muscles are extremely
important when it comes to pushing off
the ground stabilizing the foot in the
ankle but again with thick soles on we
just can't make the most of them study
show that you can train these muscles
with bands and things and they're
responsive to training and that this can
increase jump height and other factors
you actually have an exercise that i
enjoy using for strengthening the toes
specifically though and it's one that
i'm pretty sure i invented i've not seen
anyone else use anything like it i call
it the resisted forwards toe lean and
what we're going to do here is lean
forwards like michael jackson as far as
you can this only works in bare foot or
barefoot minimal shoes lean forward as
far as you can and then you dig your
toes into the ground and use that to
right yourself again
you can actually feel this work pretty
quickly as for mobility a lot of people
are actually lacking in dorsiflexion and
this is one of the biggest issues you
like to see with ankles and this can
greatly reduce mobility when it comes to
getting into a deep squat and also for
running and generally performing
optimally it can also lead to injuries
very commonly so if you struggle to get
right down into a deep resting squat
because you feel like you're going to
fall backwards the limiting factor here
is most likely dorsiflexion the issue
might well be tight carves essentially
this means that you can't get your
center of gravity forward enough which
means you're now going to rock backwards
either that you're going to need to bend
your spine around to compensate which is
going to create an issue you also likely
see this a lot if you struggle with the
pistol squat if you keep rolling
backwards when you're trying to do a
pistol squat that's very likely due to
issues with your ankle mobility
one solution i've not really seen people
talk about is to be more actively
engaging the tibialis anterior whilst
you're in this position so pulling
yourself forwards that makes it a more
active mobility challenge rather than a
passive stretch
and it improves the mind muscle
connection
you can just rock in position like this
not using your weight but by actively
dorsiflexing and at the same time by
just using your weight and momentum
it's a great way to gently improve that
mobility this is where a goblet squat
also comes in handy
by holding a weight like this not only
do you provide yourself with that
counterbalance but at the same time you
weight yourself forwards making this a
light weighted stretch that will improve
that ankle mobility very gently
and there is another way you can test
whether or not you have enough range of
motion
using a tape measure which i'll show you
in a second and okay fine
i'll take off my top just for this last
bit
so what you want to do is find yourself
a wall should have a few of those
knocking around and a tape measure open
out to five inches place it in front of
the wall and place your toes so they're
five inches
away from the wall now what you're going
to do is keeping your heel on that foot
flat on the floor bend your knee forward
and see if you can touch the wall and if
you
can then your ankle mobility is adequate
for most of the things you're likely to
want to do if you can't then you've got
a little bit of a room for improvement
and like i said you can do this with a
bunch of different calf stretches that
could include things like the elephant
walk like downward dog or alternatively
that deep deficit calf race that we were
just talking about
and of course another one is the atg
split squat which again is a knees over
toes guy staple
if your calves don't seem particularly
tight but you still struggle to get into
that position the issue here might be a
physical blockage preventing your foot
from moving upwards and you'll know this
because it'll feel like a blockage it
might even hurt a little bit but the
good news is that this can be fixed as
well with bandage joint distractions so
what we're going to do here is wrap a
band around the foot
let's get the shoe off again
between where the bridge of the foot
meets
the bottom of the shin
which is called the talus and we're
going to try and pull it back and down
this is basically going to pull the
phibia back into alignment so that we
can bend our foot upwards again your
pocket band
find an anchor point
that could be a table leg a heavy table
leg i'm actually going to use a
kettlebell here which is fine because i
just need to use my other foot to keep
that in place and i'm also going to use
my other foot to pin the band downwards
to keep that angle
how i want it
so i put my foot on the kettlebell
and see it's across
where the bridge of the foot meets the
tibia and the fibula
pulling down
on that tailless bone
now i'm just going to bend nice and
forward
as you're doing this you should
immediately
find that you can
lean your foot forwards more than you
could before hold this position for 5 to
10 seconds repeat 15 times and you
should find that you immediately
following this have a deeper squat and
feel less discomfort when you get into
that position this helped me immediately
to increase my range of motion and to
ease off some of the ankle pain i've
experienced in the past
hopefully it could do the same for some
of you
two great sources for more on those
specific joint distractions are scott
university and athlete next check them
out if you want more advice like that so
thanks so much for watching this one
guys i hope you found it useful and
interesting if you did then please
consider liking sharing it around that
would help me out immensely subscribe if
you want to see more like this hit the
bell button for notifications and if you
like this kind of training that improves
your general performance working on not
only strength and balance balls mobility
explosiveness even brain function you
might enjoy my new ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
the protein performance system you'll
find a link that down in the description
down below it's over two hours of video
content showing you how to form all of
the movements plus an in-depth 80 plus
page ebook and of course a complete
workout designed to build all those
things all at once yeah if you found
this useful then you should get a ton of
benefit from that training program
either way thank you so much for
watching
and bye for now
you